roddick qui c'est celui-là mon frère
s'appelle jacques
moi comme je dis toujours si t'as pas un
peignoir et des bulles à 50 ans tu as
pas réussi ta vie ou la carte club oui
accueillir ceux qui n'ont rien ces
principes de toulouse emmaüs
bon c'est vrai il faudra bosser ou bien
sûr bien sûr c'est prévu j'avais lu un
article comme quoi des tas de
milliardaire avait commencé dans leur
garage
je voulais inventer un truc simple et
donc il me rendrai riches comme kirby
stud book ou laisser l'amérique héros
l'avait pourquoi je me suis fait chier a
trouvé une idée géniale c'est quoi ta
grand débat l'idée c'est de rendre les
petites gens beaux
un gros potentiel de séduction c'est à
dire est de sentir sa chrysalide
10 - le secrétaire réussite s'il te
plaît jacques pas ce qui compte
maintenant c'est l'individu et connaît
la trump tower
non je suis jamais battu voilà je
verrais bien ma tour pourra tower pas
vraiment vous n'avez jamais clos capital
de karl marx qui va t'aider à avoir un
jacuzzi ou une pergola chaque jusqu'à
présent n'a réussi à vivre ensemble sans
que l'argent nous pourissent c'est pou
alors cache pas tout j'avais reçu
quelque chose et sa faillite à coups de
cul
j'ai commencé avec un peignoir et des
mules